over the last decade milk has become a
bit controversial
some people say it's a necessary and
nutritious food vital for healthy bones
but others say it can cause cancer and
lead to an early death
so who's right and why are we drinking
it anyway
[Music]
milk is the basis of every mammal's diet
after birth when our digestive systems
are immature and small
basically it's power food to kick-start
our bodies and help us grow
milk is rich in fat vitamins minerals
and milk sugar lactose
on top of that for a while after birth
it also contains antibodies and proteins
that protect us from infections and
regulate our immune system
but it's a lot of effort for mothers to
produce
eventually humans stop drinking mother's
milk and transition to the diet of their
parents
this is how it's been for thousands of
years
until about 11 000 years ago when our
ancestors settled down in the first
agricultural communities
soon they domesticated the first dairy
animals goats sheep and cattle
they found that dairy animals are able
to eat useless and abundant stuff and
turn it into nutritious and tasty food
this made a huge difference in terms of
survival especially in hard times
so groups that had milk available had an
evolutionary advantage
and through natural selection it changed
the genes of communities who consumed a
lot of it
this adaptation has to do with a
specialized enzyme lactase
babies have a lot of it in their system
so they can break down the milk sugar
lactose and digest milk easily
but the older we grow the fewer lactase
enzymes our body produces
worldwide about 65 percent of the
population do not have the enzyme after
infancy which means they are not able to
digest more than about 150 milliliters
each day
this lactose intolerance is not spread
evenly around the world though
in some east asian communities for
example it's up to 90 percent
in northern europe and north america the
rates are the lowest overall
[Music]
there are probably a few reasons for
this uneven distribution the trait was
first introduced by random mutation
which happened independently of each
other in a few populations
the fact that farming replaced hunting
and gathering more and more created
natural selection pressure
people who were able to digest lactose
had more foods at hand which was an
advantage
the migration of dairy farmers to the
north then spread it further which
probably pushed back populations there
that didn't have the trait
okay but if milk has been a valuable
part of our diet for thousands of years
why is it so controversial
there are a number of claims regarding
the negative and positive health effects
of milk
the negative ones cover a wide variety
from brittle bones to cancer and
cardiovascular diseases to intolerance
and allergies
so how do they hold up
some older studies found a connection
between milk and a high risk of breast
colon and prostate cancer
but meta-analyses found no impact on
your cancer risk
on the contrary the calcium in milk
might even have a protective effect
against colon cancer although this could
be calcium in general it's not clear
milk plays a role in this effect
only studies on prostate cancer showed
an increased risk for people who
consumed more than one and a quarter
liters of milk a day but again the
association is inconsistent and other
studies don't find any effect
we discussed these studies in more
detail in our sources document all in
all the research seems to show that if
you drink between 100 to 250 milliliters
of milk per day cancer is not a concern
similarly meta-analyses could not find
any impact from milk or dairy products
on your risk of heart disease stroke or
your total mortality
some studies even suggested that high
blood pressure might be rarer in people
who eat a lot of dairy although the
evidence is not strong enough to claim
this with confidence
the case gets more complicated though
when we look at bones a number of
studies found neither positive nor
negative effects for adults
what most people worry most about though
are harmful amounts of pesticides
antibiotics or hormones
there are hormones in milk but only in
very low concentrations
for example to get the same amount of
hormones as from the pill you'd need to
drink about 5000 liters of milk and even
if you did most hormones would be
destroyed by your digestive system
before they could affect you
which is the reason why so much
medication is coated to protect it from
our digestion
for pesticides and antibiotics there are
regulations in most parts of the world
that only allow completely harmless
amounts
milk that surpasses these thresholds is
not allowed to go on the shelf so
there's nothing in particular to worry
about
besides allergies and those suffering
from lactose intolerances the best known
negative effects of milk are probably
acne and general discomfort after
drinking milk or eating dairy products
and here the effects are very real for
example skimmed milk has been found to
statistically increase the rate of acne
by 24 percent allergies against milk
products are especially prevalent among
children with one in 18 kids in germany
suffering from them in general these
allergies tend to get better or
disappear as they grow older though
ok is milk healthy then
milk no matter if it comes from mothers
cows sheep goats or camels is a nutrient
dense food
it contains all necessary macronutrients
and many micronutrients
especially in regions where people
struggle to get enough calories milk can
contribute to a healthy life and lower
child mortality
for those living in the developed world
in general milk is not harmful if you
are not allergic or intolerant to it
especially for children it's a good way
to get large amounts of calcium and for
vegetarians it's a good source of
vitamin b12 and b vitamins in general
this does not mean there are not other
alternatives with the same effect you do
not need to drink milk to be healthy
milk is also definitely not a substitute
for water
milk is power food and the additional
calories from drinking a lot of it on a
regular basis can contribute to being
overweight
especially flavored milk or chocolate
milk is more comparable to beverages
like lemonade than a healthy snack
and there's another thing to consider
milk production has a significant impact
on the global climate
about 33 percent of cropland is used to
feed grazing animals including dairy
cattle
even though the carbon footprint of
dairy products has declined since 1990
dairy production is still responsible
for three percent of all greenhouse gas
emissions even more than all aeroplanes
combined
milk is a huge industry and sadly most
of its production in factory farms
causes incredible suffering
[Music]
are impregnated over and over separated
from their young shortly after birth and
slaughtered once their tortured bodies
are not productive anymore
we can't ignore that much of the milk we
consume stems from an industry that is
basically torture and contribute to
climate change
what about plant-based milk
in terms of protein levels and
nutritional value only soy milk can
compare to cow milk the others need to
be artificially enriched to reach
similar levels of vitamins and calcium
so they can be an alternative to milk
and another option might be available
soon
several startups have created non-animal
milk that is nutritionally identical to
dairy milk for example through
fermentation by gene-modified bacteria
this lab-grown milk can even be turned
into cheese something that plant-based
alternatives struggle with because they
lack casein and whey protein the key
ingredients that give dairy its taste
and structure
the environmental impact is a different
story though
many milk alternatives use significantly
less energy land and less water to
produce
so they have a much lower environmental
impact than animal milk
if you want to have the lowest possible
negative impact on the planet the best
choice is whatever milk alternative is
regional
as with almost any topic milk is
complicated
it's not harmful for the majority of the
population and it's crucial for many
people around the world
it's good nutritious food but also
harmful to the planet and causes a lot
of suffering
we need to decide as a society how we
want to deal with these facts
wait
[Music]